start today show at a luxurious holiday
themed winter Terrace yes Rocky shows us
how we can chill in style in Henderson
if you're ready to escape the strip you
can come down to a winter wonderland
here in Henderson at the Green Valley
Ranch winter at the Terrace first and
foremost you get to take a fabulous
picture here yes ma'am and then go enjoy
of course yes ma'am introduce us to this
experience of course so essentially what
we've done is transform our Terrace area
into a Whimsical winter wonderland for
our guests to enjoy now in this winter
wonderland you'll find some traditional
elements like igloos and fire pits
however we've customized The Experience
out of our own little gdr flare
particularly with the food and beverage
that we have to offer okay now you have
to explain further what the gvr flare is
I'm curious so with this being an Off
the Strip property we're focused more on
providing our guests that luxury
experience and that again of course
trickles over into these little pop-up
seasonal lounges that we have much like
winter at the Terrace absolutely now
you're the resort Butler it's very cool
so you're the ultimate host yes ma'am so
let's talk parties what the vibe is over
here because it starts at 4 P.M right
when the Sun goes down right yes ma'am
it does so as far as hours of operations
are concerned the lounge itself is open
Sunday through Thursday from 4 P.M till
9 p.m and then from 4 pm to 11 pm on
Friday and Saturdays okay now are there
packages is or any you know anything
that people need to know when they're
coming down with the group look at we
got our guests here and doing the
s'mores and like during let's see a
little marshmallow on your face there
buddy
enjoying the experience I'm loving it
yes ma'am again just speaking to the
fact that guests come here to enjoy
themselves and obviously we like
providing our guests and style
experience as well now besides the
s'mores we're talking Italy's because I
think it's just so cool inside what can
you get so as far as the igloos are
concerned obviously as we'll get to a
little bit later there are an array of
food and beverage options that we can
provide our guests as well we take great
pride in doing so and obviously our food
and beverage team as well as our
corporate mixologist takes great pride
in providing our guests these awesome
menus with an array of options which
we'll get to in just a bit as well okay
as we've had awesome food and beverages
so we're gonna go inside that igloo and
try it for ourselves yes ma'am send it
back here
thank you Rob